[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas a lo largo de las semanas
relacionadas con la pandemia del comil
19 soy santiago lópez gonzález y a
continuación les presento el sumario de
temas que tenemos para este programa
veamos
vamos a comenzar en la argentina con
nuestro corresponsal natalio cos hoy
conversaremos sobre los avances que ha
tenido la investigación del escándalo
conocido como vacunas vip y siguen
dándose a conocer más nombres y siguen
dándose a conocer más detalles de cómo
fue para la planeado este entramado
también vamos a conversar sobre el
regreso a clases en argentina un amplio
debate que enfrenta a los padres de
familia a los alumnos a las autoridades
y por supuesto a los centros educativos
también esta semana fue destacado que en
estados unidos superaron las 500 mil
víctimas mortales por el cob y 19 el
presidente joe biden realizó un homenaje
precisamente a las víctimas allí en la
ciudad de washington en este país
también posiblemente entre en
circulación la vacuna desarrollada por
johnson y johnson que podría ser
autorizada para su uso de emergencia en
la unión americana y así reforzar el
plan de vacunación estadounidense que es
el líder mundial en número de inoculados
y llegaron a territorio uruguayo las
primeras 140.000 dosis de la vacuna de
sinovac desarrollada en chino
de esta manera uruguay que era uno de
los últimos países de la región en
comenzar a inmunizar espera poner en
marcha entonces un plan de vacunación
muy ambicioso por parte del gobierno que
espera inmunidad total de los 3.5
millones de ciudadanos en muy pocos
meses
uruguay también se prepara para el
regreso a clases como argentina ya
veremos cómo se están preparando allí
los comenzamos el programa y comenzamos
entonces en argentina esta semana este
país fue sacudido por ese escándalo
conocido como vacunas vip y al menos 70
funcionarios fueron vacunados de manera
secreta y anticipada fueron dadas a
conocer unas listas de vacunación
oficiales y unas listas de vacunación
paralelas que indicaban quienes debían o
no inocularse en esa fase número 1 el
escándalo le costó el cargo al ministro
de salud el presidente alberto fernández
condenó que los turnos de vacunación no
fueran respetados y calificó como una
verdadera payasada el despliegue que
estaba teniendo este escándalo en los
medios de comunicación argentinos
crece la polémica en argentina con el
caso de las vacunas vip y hasta 70
personalidades fueron vacunadas
supuestamente antes de tiempo según la
prensa local el ministerio de salud
operó con un circuito paralelo de hasta
tres mil vacunas que tenía como base el
hospital posadas en el área
metropolitana de la capital es una
indignación total lo que utilizan a
nuestros hospitales a la salud pública
para mostrar una pantalla que bueno
ahora sale al alumno
el negocio el gran negocio que para eso
fue en esta pandemia la enfermedad
y nosotros estamos en lista de espera
esperando la vacunación
desde el mes de diciembre el escándalo
salió a la luz después de que el
periodista horacio verbitsky confesara
que fue vacunado y afecta a grandes
nombres el principal es el presidente
alberto fernández que recibió una dosis
de sputnik be junto a varios miembros de
su equipo fernández condenó que alguien
se adelante en la vacunación pero
advirtió que el escándalo mediático es
una payasada asegurando que él se vacunó
para dar ejemplo mire si hay más
responsables y van a tener lo que se
tengan que ir
porque nunca me promovía vale nada de
eso
pero también digo no voy a hacerme cargo
del escarnio público que están
promoviendo
sin medida y en argentina la lista
también apunta al ministro felipe solá y
su equipo y al titular de la cartera de
economía martín guzmán además de al ex
presidente interino eduardo duhalde y su
familia o destacados periodistas
embajadores y diputados el ex ministro
de salud ginés gonzález ya renunció por
su implicación en el caso el viernes
pasado y ahora mismo está siendo
investigado por un fiscal este tipo de
escándalos no son nuevos en américa
latina' en perú hasta 470 personalidades
fueron salpicadas por el vacuna gay
vamos a conversar con natalio cos hoy
nuestro corresponsable en argentina para
conocer más detalles de la situación
allí
natalio ya nos pusimos en contexto en
torno a este caso de las vacunas vip y
en qué va esta investigación qué
novedades hay
así el escándalo de las vacunaciones vip
así se dio a conocer en argentina es
algo que seguramente no va a terminar
todavía es cierto el estado nacional
después de que renunciar el que fue
ministro de salud ginés gonzález garcía
y fuera reemplazado por carla vizzotti
actual ministra de salud dé a conocer
una lista de 70 nombres de personas que
habían sido vacunadas si se quiere
salteando las listas de espera en
algunos casos fueron justificadas estas
vacunaciones por el estado nacional pero
la vacunación en argentina está
esencialmente descentralizada y cada
distrito cada provincia es la que se
hace cargo de las vacunaciones por eso
ya vimos y seguiremos viendo seguramente
casos similares en las provincias y en
los municipios es algo que seguramente
no ha terminado todavía por lo pronto
bueno el presidente como dije le había
pedido la renuncia al ministro de salud
también se quejó de que se hubieran
abierto causas judiciales en ese sentido
porque insistió en que no hay delito y
que las medidas que se tuvieron que
tomar se tomaron de hecho la ministra
cal
aviso ti preciso a través de una
resolución del ministerio de salud
quienes son aquellos considerados
personal estratégico que es una figura
que se utilizó para para vacunar algunas
de estas personas que aparecían en la
lista de 70 y dio una definición más
concreta de la que existía hasta ahora y
además de unos requisitos que implican
por ejemplo que el nombre de aquel que
se ha vacunado o aquellas que sea
vacunada como personal estratégico pueda
ser difundido a la población
natalio argentina ha estado inmersa en
un largo debate sobre si regresar a las
clases o mantenerlas virtuales o
regresar a clases presenciales que dicen
allí
si esta semana se está regresando a las
clases a las clases presenciales
progresivamente aquí en argentina hugo
en 2020 después de que todas las aulas
cerraran en marzo de 2020 hubo algunos
intentos de regreso en algunas pequeñas
localidades y provincias pero se tuvo
que dar marcha atrás ahora es algo a
nivel nacional en todo el país están
reabriendo los diferentes niveles
educativos y es un desafío enorme
implicó entre otras cosas negociaciones
entre los gobiernos nacionales y locales
provinciales y los sindicatos docentes
por ejemplo y es algo que apenas está
empezando ahora y hay que ver cómo
progresa cómo funcionan los protocolos
con las burbujas la distancia social los
horarios escalonados y en algunos casos
también la combinación con educación a
modalidad a distancia qué es lo que
estuvo vigente durante todo 2007 por lo
pronto el gobierno anunció que el
personal que trabaja en centros
educativos docentes y no docentes van a
recibir una vacuna que acaba de llegar
al país este jueves en un primer lote de
un poco más de 900.000 dosis se
completará el millón de dosis la vacuna
sino farm como no puede ser dada mayores
de 60 se va a aprovechar y se va a
vacunar con esa vacuna el personal de
centros educativos va a alcanzar para
medio millón de personas sobre un total
estimado de un millón 450 mil
trabajadores de la educación en el país
natalio hacia allá se dirige mi
siguiente pregunta cómo está avanzando
la vacunación en reportamos que llegaron
y usted nos decía que llegaron estas
dosis de la vacuna desarrollada en china
argentina venia inoculando solamente
vacunas rusas
si hasta el viernes por la mañana se
habían aplicado en argentina más de
900.000 dosis de las dos vacunas que
había disponibles hasta ahora en el país
las public be de origen ruso y lackovic
el que es una vacuna que se fabrica en
india bajo licencia de la vacuna de
oxford y astrazéneca hay distribuidas en
realidad hubo una distribución de más de
1.700.000 vacunas de 700.000 dosis en
todo el país pero cada cada distrito
está avanzando a ritmo diferente por eso
la aplicación hasta ahora había sido de
900.000 sobre ese millón 700 mil de
dosis entonces es un avance desparejo a
nivel país no todas las provincias están
avanzando a la misma velocidad la ciudad
de buenos aires por ejemplo esta semana
inició la vacunación en mayores de 80
con una serie de turnos que había que
requerir a través de internet y se
agotaron muy rápidamente con bastantes
dificultades pero ya inicio y ya hay
mayores de 80 siendo vacunados y algunos
que ya se vacunaron y algo similar está
pasando en la provincia de buenos aires
donde había iniciado antes la vacunación
en adultos mayores y sigue avanzando
pero todo depende y este es el gran
cuello de botella
que lleguen nuevas dosis de vacunas y
entonces esta es si se quiere la gran
dificultad que enfrenta como todo el
mundo argentina también se espera que
lleguen 600.000 dosis de comisión de
esta vacuna que mencionaba antes hacia
marzo
y además están pendientes el grueso la
mayor parte de los 20 millones de dosis
que se habían acordado de sputnik ve y
casi 22,5 millones de dosis de la vacuna
de oxford y astrazéneca que todavía no
están llegando al país además este
viernes se conoció que el laboratorio
nacional argentino richmond está en
negociaciones en conversaciones con el
instituto gamma leia de rusia para ver
si eventualmente mínimo seguramente en
un año se puede empezar a fabricar la
vacuna sputnik de aquí en el país a
través de más cómo se desarrolla
entonces esa vacunación allí en
argentina gracias a natalio por este
reporte desde la ciudad de buenos aires
nos vamos del extremo sur a el extremo
norte eeuu superó la barrera de las 500
mil víctimas mortales por kobe 19 a la
fecha de hoy son 508 mil 750 personas
que han fallecido
siguiente jobvite encabezó un acto
conmemorativo y un minuto de silencio
también en memoria de los fallecidos
baiden instó a los ciudadanos a luchar
en conjunto contra la pandemia del cobi
19 ya dejar de lado por completo esas
diferencias políticas
banderas a media asta velas y el
replique de las campanas en honor a las
vidas perdidas por el cob y 19 en eeuu
el presidente demócrata joe biden y la
vicepresidenta kamala harris rindieron
un solemne homenaje en la casa blanca
cuando la nación supera la trágica cifra
del medio millón de decesos
es comer
hoy pido a todos los estadounidenses que
recuerden recuerden a los que perdimos
ya los que nos dejaron atrás pero
mientras recordamos mientras todos
recordamos también pido que actuemos que
permanezcamos atentos que nos
mantengamos socialmente distantes que
usemos mascarillas que nos vacunemos
cuando nos toque que facsa de morelia
eeuu epicentro de la enfermedad mundial
marca un sombrío hito más
estadounidenses han fallecido en un año
por la pandemia que durante ambas
guerras mundiales y la guerra de vietnam
juntas
si bien los estadounidenses son el 4% de
la población global representan el 20
por ciento de los decesos totales por
coronavirus en el mundo y cuentan además
con más de 28 millones de contagios
muchos intentan ahora buscar respuestas
a estos datos que reflejan una falta de
unificación nacional para contener la
enfermedad durante el último mandato de
donald trump
eso no explica como un país rico y
sofisticado puede tener el mayor
porcentaje de muertes y ser el país más
afectado del mundo creo que eso no
debería haber ocurrido
brawn tickets y no y no creo que sea ya
sabes todo donald trump o todo esto y
aquello es una combinación de cosas y
ciertamente la falta de implicación en
la muy muy alta cúpula de la dirección
pese al avance de una campaña que ya ha
vacunado a casa
20 de la población las autoridades
proyectan más de 600.000 muertes para el
1 de junio vamos a profundizar en este
tema con mamá en sala nuestra
corresponsable en la ciudad de nueva
york o la mamen ya lo veíamos en el
reporte son más de 500 mil víctimas
mortales hubo homenajes es una cifra
enorme como recibe eeuu
este número de fallecidos
si eeuu ha superado esa terrible barrera
psicológica del medio millón de
fallecidos por kobe 19 que supera con
creces y muy de lejos a las peores
previsiones que se hicieron al principio
de la pandemia sobre el número de
fallecidos por cada una de estas vidas
el presidente de joe biden pidió esta
semana un minuto de silencio que realizó
acompañado de la vicepresidenta kamala
harris y de los cónyuges de ambos
mientras que en washington las banderas
ondeaban a media asta y las campanas de
la catedral repicaban en honor a esos
fallecidos por el kobe 19 yobái del
lanzó un emotivo discurso en el que
pidió respeto para los fallecidos y
cuidar a los vivos además dijo sin
separaciones por partidos y con mucha
precaución y prestando mucha atención
porque lo peor todavía no ha pasado y
hay que seguir luchando contra el virus
para que no crezcan los casos impactante
también santiago ha sido la portada que
ha hecho esta semana el 'new york times'
en honor a esas
a más de 500.000 personas fallecidas con
el cubo y 19 no sé si lo podéis apreciar
pero es una gráfica con pequeños puntos
y cada uno de estos puntitos representa
pues una de las vidas perdidas en esta
pantalla también fue muy comentada esa
portada a nivel internacional
independiente de estos números que no
son muy alentadores la cifra de
hospitalización si ha comenzado a
disminuir en toda la unión americana
si en estos momentos de eeuu supera los
28 millones de infectados por kobe y 19
pero la buena noticia es que los
contagios están cayendo dicen los
expertos que es gracias a que cada vez
hay un uso más extendido
de las mascarillas y por supuesto a ese
plan de vacunación también están cayendo
las hospitalizaciones hasta niveles que
no habíamos visto desde el pasado mes de
noviembre algo que bueno que es una
buena noticia sobre todo teniendo en
cuenta que venimos después de haber
acabado enero que ha sido el mes más
letal de toda la pandemia en este país
ahora si el director del centro de
control y prevención de enfermedades
dice que los datos siguen siendo todavía
muy malos y los expertos no se cansan de
repetir a la población que no se baje la
guardia porque todavía queda mucho por
hacer sobre todo por esas nuevas cepas
que poco a poco van llegando a este país
la última que se ha descubierto ha sido
precisamente aquí en nueva york' y es
una cepa que preocupa mucho a los
científicos porque como otras anteriores
parece ser que su grado de contagio
mucho más rápido que el virus original
hablemos de la vacuna de johnson y
johnson que va a ser aprobada
próximamente en ese país todo parece
indicar que así va a hacer que planes
para su distribución allí para reforzar
ese plan de vacunación que es el líder a
nivel internacional
si con estas ya serían tres las vacunas
que tiene ahora mismo eeuu para hacer
frente al cubo 19 a ésta se le unen la
de facer y la de moderna que son las que
se están administrando ahora en estos
momentos un comité de expertos
independientes de la de la edad que es
la agencia reguladora del medicamento
aquí en este país se está reuniendo para
dar lugar a la aprobación del uso de
emergencia de esa vacuna hay que decir
que la rda esta semana ya dijo que sí
que es cierto que esa vacuna reúne todas
las condiciones necesarias de seguridad
para poder ser administrada y en
cualquier momento a parece ser que
podría ser mañana mismo se aprobaría esa
tercera vacuna
johnson and johnson ha dicho que tiene
disponibles inmediatamente cuatro
millones de dosis y que para finales de
marzo podría tener disponible 20
millones más como sabéis esta vacuna se
administra solamente con un pinchazo
tiene un 66 por ciento de efectividad y
precisamente el hecho de que sea una
sola dosis
de la ciudad de nueva york a prometer un
proyecto que seguramente arrancará el
mes que viene y que consiste en
administrar la vacuna con un servicio a
domicilio a aquellas personas que no
puedan moverse de su casa dadas las
facilidades que ofrece el que la vacuna
solamente consta de una dosis también
hace algunos días reportamos ese
temporal de nieve y de bajas
temperaturas que afectó a buena parte de
eeuu como retraso esto el plan de
vacunación y qué están haciendo ahora
para reactivarlo y volver a llegar a
esas zonas remotas que se vieron
afectadas
si esa ola de frío y ese temporal de
tormentas que ha asolado eeuu en los
últimos días ha afectado también a la
distribución de las vacunas en todo el
país poquito a poco se empieza a
recuperar el ritmo pero todavía está
costando para que solo es una idea la
semana pasada explicábamos que se iban a
comenzar a administrar las vacunas en
miles en 6000 farmacias repartidas en
todo el país pues bien la mayoría de
ellas no han podido recibir estas
vacunas y muchos han tenido que
reprogramar a las citas con los
pacientes y en algunos lugares como por
ejemplo en texas donde la tormenta ha
pegado todavía más fuerte que en otros
países y ha habido cortes de
electricidad o se han tenido que llevar
las vacunas a otros sitios para que no
se perdieran debido a sus cortes de
electricidad no que habían roto esa
cadena de frío pero bueno poquito a poco
se va recuperando y se espera que entre
estos días como muy tarde la semana que
viene la mayoría de estas farmacias ya
puedan comenzar a administrar estas
dosis para que os hagáis una idea ahora
mismo según el centro de control de
prevención de enfermedades ante estados
unidos hay más de 68 mil
de vacunas administradas en todo el país
y un 66 por ciento de la población está
completamente inmunizaba es decir ha
recibido ya las dos dosis
muchas gracias mamen por este reporte
desde la ciudad de nueva york que
poniéndonos al tanto de la situación en
eeuu veamos entonces cómo están las
cifras como indican que están avanzando
los planes de vacunación en el
continente americano al día de hoy
américa del sur lleva en total
12.17 millones de dosis inoculadas en el
continente americano ya lo decíamos eeuu
lidera también lo hace a nivel mundial
con más de 68 millones de dosis pero
brasil reporta 7.80 millones de dosis
inoculadas le sigue chile con 3.21
millones de dosis luego méxico con 2.09
millones canadá registra 1.71 millones
de dosis ya inoculadas mientras que el
top 5 lo cierra argentina con 829 mil
832 dosis a partir de ahí el registro
continúa en su estricto orden de la
siguiente manera perú costa rica panamá
colombia ecuador
bolivia el salvador trinidad y tobago
guyana con más de 800 dosis ya
inoculadas y las islas malvinas en el
atlántico sur en donde han inoculado más
de 1500 dosis en sus poco más de 3 mil
500 habitantes
y vamos a actualizar entonces la
situación en brasil en donde esta semana
hubo varias noticias para reportar en
torno a la pandemia del cob y 19 vamos
entonces a conectar con valeria saccone
la corresponsal de france 24 en río de
janeiro ahora valeria y dentro de las
novedades está que las autoridades de la
ciudad de sao paulo instauraron
nuevamente el toque de queda porque
vuelven a imponer esta restricción
sample es el estado más poblado de
brasil y también uno de los más
afectados por la pandemia de el
coronavirus precisamente para intentar
paliar los efectos de esta segunda ola
de contagios en san paolo el gobernador
acaba de introducir un toque de queda
hasta el 14 de febrero los habitantes de
los 645 municipios de ese estado
federado no podrán circular entre las 23
de la noche y las 5 de la mañana
obviamente con la excepción de los
trabajadores que tienen que regresar a
sus casas
la razón está clara sampalo tiene las
peores cifras de hospitalizaciones desde
el inicio de la pandemia los hospitales
públicos tienen una ocupación del 70% y
en los privados la ocupación es de entre
80 y 100 por cien mientras en todo
brasil por causa de la variante
amazónica del virus se produce un
contagio cada tres segundos
valeri ha habido muchas denuncias a
través de las redes sociales de falsas
vacunaciones personas mayores que se van
a inocular les ponen la inyección pero
no les inoculan el antídoto como tal que
es lo que dicen las autoridades
la vacunación en brasil avanza a
trompicones la semana pasada en ciudades
como río de janeiro y salvador de bahía
fue interrumpida por falta de dosis y
sólo fue reanudada esta semana sabemos
que de momento se han aplicado 66
millones de dosis según datos del
ministerio de salud lo que equivale más
o menos al 3 por ciento de la población
mientras se multiplican las denuncias
por las llamadas vacunaciones de viento
eso es enfermeros que en vez de aplicar
la vacuna aplican aire esto lo han
denunciado familiares de los ancianos
que están en los grupos de prioridad lo
han documentado con sus teléfonos
móviles y en este momento la la policía
de río de janeiro está investigando
varias denuncias y al menos tres
enfermeros en río de janeiro en curitiba
han sido alejados de su puesto de
trabajo mientras esta noticia ha creado
una gran conmoción en todo brasil y son
muchas las familias de esos ancianos que
están vigilando de cerca la aplicación
de la vacuna vacunación es de viento
otro escándalo más en américa latina'
valeria también ha sido destacado en
brasil a lo largo de esta semana
de facer ya fue aprobada para ser usada
allí de emergencia en brasil
esta semana la agencia nacional de
vigilancia sanitaria anvisa ha aprobado
el uso de la vacuna desarrollada por la
empresa fighter es el primer país de
américa latina que lo hace y a estas
alturas en brasil nadie esperaba esta
noticia porque el presidente y jair
bolsonaro y su ministro de salud eduardo
para suelo se opusieron desde el año
pasado a esta vacuna por las condiciones
que impone la empresa la empresa quiere
que el gobierno de brasil se
responsabiliza por todos los posibles
efectos colaterales y que no vaya a
pleito en caso de problemas de hecho el
ministro para suelo en más de una
ocasión han denunciado las cláusulas
leoninas de esta empresa mientras la
fundación oswaldo cruz se prepara para
poder empezar a producir de aquí a unos
meses la vacuna de astrazéneca en suelo
brasileño a través de la transferencia
de tecnología la idea que se produzcan
hasta tres millones de dosis por día
valeria y en brasil este país sigue
reportando unos índices de mortalidad
muy altos superaron ya las 250
mil personas fallecidas por el cubil 19
que dicen allí
brasil alcanza los 250 mil
fallecimientos en la misma semana en que
se cumple un año desde el primer
diagnóstico por corona virus es una
cifra que impacta es como si hubiesen
muerto los espectadores de tres estadios
maracanás llenos sin embargo hay que
recordar que brasil no es el país que
más muerto tiene si los tiene en
términos absolutos es el segundo país
solo por detrás de los eeuu pero si
miramos la relación de los muertos por
100.000 habitantes hay países como
inglaterra portugal italia y eeuu que
están mucho peor aún así la situación es
preocupante por culpa de la variante
amazónica del virus que está acelerando
los contagios se teme que las próximas
semanas se pueda producir una pandemia
dentro de la pandemia y que el colapso
sanitario que vivimos en manaos se puede
repetir en muchas ciudades del país
valeria muchas gracias por este reporte
desde la ciudad de río de janeiro con el
cerro pan de azúcar de fondo vamos
entonces ahora a colombia y el
presidente iván duque confirmó que el 7
de marzo llegarán a ese país dos
millones de dosis de la vacuna china
sinovac
estas dosis junto con los otros lotes
que han recibido se traducirá en una
aceleración del plan de vacunación
nacional que avanza gracias a los
aportes de los lotes que buena parte del
gobierno accedió a través del fondo
kóvacs y a través de compras directas
colombia ya ha comprado 10 millones de
dosis a este laboratorio asiático que ya
le entregó unas primeras 192 mil vacunas
en días anteriores
y ya lo habíamos destacado varias veces
en este programa uruguay es un país que
varias veces fue aplaudido a lo largo
del confinamiento fue aplaudido a nivel
internacional por el manejo de la
pandemia del cob y 19 ahora está un poco
relegado en el avance de la vacunación
este país recibió apenas su primer lote
de vacunas las autoridades uruguayas son
muy ambiciosas con este plan de
vacunación y esperan en muy pocos meses
tener inmunizadas a los más de 3.5
millones de habitantes que tiene ese
país suramericano desde montevideo car y
nada al más nos va a contar más detalles
de cómo está la situación allí hola
karina pues ya lo decíamos llegaron de
las vacunas procedentes de china un poco
tarde pero ya están allí en territorio
uruguayo como reciben esta noticia
así es santiago llegaron al país en la
madrugada de este viernes dosis del
laboratorio sinovac av uruguay uruguay
es uno de los últimos países en
sudamérica en recibir las vacunas contra
el kobe 19 esto ha sido fuertemente
criticado por la oposición quienes
también cuestionaron que el gobierno no
comprará todavía la vacuna rusa incluso
cuando este país facilitaría la
fabricación de la misma en uruguay a las
críticas el gobierno responde que quizás
uruguay sea el último país en recibir a
las vacunas pero será el primero
inmunizar al 3 por ciento de su
población concretamente uruguay ordenó 3
millones 800 mil dosis de vacunas a
facer y si novak y espera recibir un
millón y medio del programa cobarde pero
se concretaron el arribo de casi 200.000
dosis
si no van y la compra de 400.000 dosis
de kaiser karina lo importante es que
las vacunas ya están allí y van a
comenzar a hacer y no inoculadas
precisamente esa es mi siguiente
pregunta cómo va a ser este plan de
vacunación en uruguay un país que es
pequeño y que está muy bien conectado
con las diferentes regiones esto
aparentemente podría facilitarles las
cosas a las autoridades de salud
uruguayas
en la primera ronda de vacunación
recibirán la inmunización personal de
educación bomberos militares y
trabajadores de los centros de infancia
y adolescentes el presidente luis
lacalle pou indicó que los trabajadores
de la salud y los residentes en
geriátricos mayores de edad estarán
siendo parte de la segunda tanda de
vacunación porque a partir del 8 de
marzo se espera el arribo de las vacunas
de laboratorio kaiser y dado que este
tiene mayor eficacia contra el mobbing
19 es que el gobierno habría tomado esta
decisión la vacunación será voluntaria y
se pedirá también a las personas que
firmen un consentimiento informado
al recibirla
karim al igual que la mayoría de los
países en suramérica donde está
terminando el verano los padres están
listos para llevar a sus hijos a clases
y en uruguay también ha habido mucho
debate en torno a regresar a clases
presenciales hacer clases alternas hacer
clases en la virtualidad dependiendo de
cómo está avanzando la vacunación y
también dependiendo de cómo está el
ritmo de contagio en cada uno de estos
países cómo está la situación de uruguay
de cara al inicio de las clases de un
nuevo año académico
exactamente el retorno a clases era a
partir del lunes primero de marzo son de
carácter obligatorio y las autoridades
del año pasado dejaron que los adultos
decidieran si los niños volvían o no a
clases pero este año es de carácter
obligatorio por lo mismo se tuvieron que
acondicionar decenas de centros de
estudios para entre otras cosas mantener
el distanciamiento físico de los alumnos
las autoridades sanitarias pidieron
también por favor a las familias que
mantengan la burbuja de los alumnos
incluso fuera de los centros de estudio
karina el caso particular de uruguay lo
hemos estado analizando a lo largo de
toda la pandemia es un caso muy
interesante por la forma como ha
manejado precisamente el confinamiento
el cierre de las fronteras cómo está la
situación en este momento qué medidas se
mantienen que está haciendo el gobierno
ahora que el escenario le está cambiando
un poco ya hay vacunas retorno a clases
se acaba el verano muchos argentinos
regresan otra vez a su país dejando las
vacaciones de verano y el país está
parcialmente abriendo las fronteras como
siempre para uruguaya entonces cómo está
la situación
hasta el momento uruguay permanece con
sus fronteras parcialmente cerradas
sexto es que solamente ciudadanos
uruguayos y residentes legales pueden
ingresar al país y también algunos que
puedan ampararse en ciertas excepciones
que tienen que ser aprobadas por
presidencia de la república sin embargo
el gobierno está analizando la
posibilidad de dejar ingresar a aquellas
personas que ya estén vacunadas contra
el gobierno y ese 9 y puedan comprobar
que tienen anticuerpos que les permitan
no contagiarse y no contagiar a otros el
ministro de turismo cardoso pidió ya
está analizando para ver si se pueden
lograr que esta medida se apruebe para
las próximas pascuas esto generó
polémica y más que nada porque en la
región se han visto casos de corrupción
donde se
distribuyen formularios de hisopado
falsificados
gracias karina por este reporte desde
las calles de montevideo haciendo una
actualización de la situación allí
uruguay recibió sus primeras vacunas y
ya comienza su plan de vacunación en
nuestra sección en redes veamos otras
noticias destacadas de esta semana aquí
en kobe 19 la semana en américa
comenzamos en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom y esta noticia que
tuvo mucha trascendencia a lo largo de
la semana la unión europea prevé un
pasaporte para vacunados antes del
verano y abre el debate sobre
discriminación la mayoría de los países
del bloque comunitario respaldó esta
creación de un pasaporte verde para
permitir los viajes y la movilidad de
quienes ya han sido vacunados contra el
jove 19 así lo dio a conocer la
canciller alemana angela merkel quien
indicó que la iniciativa estará lista
antes del inicio del verano
pasamos ahora a centroamérica nicaragua
espera ciento treinta y cinco mil dosis
de la vacuna de astrazéneca contra el
hobbit 19 el gobierno de ese país
centroamericano informó que está a 135
mil dosis van a llegar en los próximos
días no especificaron cuando así lo voy
a conocer la vicepresidenta de nicaragua
rosario murillo
la vacuna de astrazéneca todavía no ha
sido aprobada para ser usada de
emergencia nicaragua hasta ahora sólo la
vacuna sputnik vez de rusia y la cob y
hilde india tienen ya este certificado
de uso de emergencia en nicaragua
y finalizamos en suramérica en paraguay
este país registra un pico de casos de
contagio de kobe 19 nunca antes visto en
lo que llevan de la pandemia la
dirección de vigilancia sanitaria del
ministerio de salud de ese país
suramericano indicó que están
registrando un pico de contagios nunca
antes presenciado con más de 1000 nuevos
casos diarios esto representa un 20 por
ciento de incremento adicionalmente
paraguay también comenzó ya su plan de
vacunación con cerca de 4 mil dosis de
la vacuna rusa sputnik ve que ha pedido
de un total de un millón de dosis este
país espera recibir 4.3 millones de
dosis de la vacuna de astrazéneca a
través del mecanismo
kóvacs
es todo por el momento aquí en comic 19
la semana en américa siga con nuestra
programación
[Música]